dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean I say here what
is super resolution super resolution is
a process where our input is a coarse
low resolution image and the output is
the same image but now with more details
and in high resolution
we'll also refer to this process as
image upscaling
and in this piece of work we are
interested in performing single image
super resolution which means that no
additional data is presented to the
algorithm that could help the process
despite the incredible results seen in
practically any of the crime-solving
television shows out there
our intuition would perhaps say that
this problem for the first sight sounds
impossible how could one mathematically
fill in the details when these details
are completely unknown well that's only
kind of true let's not confuse super
resolution with image in painting where
we essentially cut an entire part out of
an image and try to replace it leaning
on our knowledge of the surroundings of
the missing part that's a different
problem here the entirety of the image
is known and the details require some
enhancing and this particular method is
not based on neural networks but is
still a learning-based technique the
cool thing here is that we can use a
training data set that is for all
intents and purposes arbitrarily large
we can just grab a high resolution image
convert it to a lower resolution and we
immediately have our hands on a training
example for the learning algorithm these
would be the before-and-after images if
you will and here during learning the
image is subdivided into small image
patches and buckets are created to
aggregate the information between
patches that share similar features
these features include brightness
textures and the orientation of the
edges the technique looks at how the
small and large resolution images relate
to each other when viewed through the
lengths of these features to remarkably
interesting things arose from this
experiment one it outperforms existing
neural network based techniques and
- it only uses 10,000 images and one
hour of training time which is in the
world of deep neural networks is so
little it's completely unheard of
insanity really really well done
some tricks are involved to keep the
memory consumption low the paper
discusses how it is done and there are
also plenty of other details within make
sure to have a look as always it is
linked in the video description it can
either be run directly on the low
resolution image or alternatively we can
first run a cheap and naive decade-old
of scaling algorithm and run this
technique on the upscale output to
improve it
note that super resolution is a
remarkably competitive field of research
there are hundreds and hundreds of
papers appearing on this every year and
almost every single one of them seems to
be miles ahead of the previous ones
where in reality the truth is that most
of these methods have different
weaknesses and strengths and so far I
haven't seen any technique that would be
viable for universal use to make sure
that a large number of cases is covered
the authors posted a sizable
supplementary document with comparisons
this gives so much more credence to the
results I am hoping to see a more
widespread adoption of this in future
papers in this area for now when viewing
websites I feel that we are close to the
point where we could choose to transmit
only the lower resolution images through
the network and perform super resolution
on them locally on our phones and
computers this will lead to significant
savings on network bandwidth we are
living amazing times indeed if you are
enjoying the series make sure to
subscribe to the channel or you can also
pick up really cool perks on our patreon
page through this icon with the letter P
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
you